our eight news now investigators
continue to question safety on public
buses here in the valley they first
showed you this video of a stabbing
death of a man as he pleads to be let
off knew it for the stabbing you haven't
heard about until right now news now
investigator David charns across the
studio with the details that he has
uncovered well Brian source is now
telling the news now investigators a bus
Supervisor was stabbed several times
it's actually happened last Monday very
early in the morning here at the
Bonville Transit Center that is downtown
no public agency said anything about
this stabbing which we're told involved
the passenger stabbing a supervisor
until we reported it earlier today the
supervisor works for one of the
companies RTC contracts with to provide
bus service amid several high-profile
incidents on buses including that murder
on the bus we sat down with RTC to talk
about beefing up security now we did
this interview before last Monday
stabbing
one incident is always one too many and
it's just like all the other Transit
agencies uh in the US we've seen a spike
um an incident just we're basically a
microcosmos of what's happening in in
the the community RTC pointing out 41
million passengers rode the bus last
year it's upgrading cameras on buses so
police can actually look inside them
real time they also point out there are
200 security officers in the system
across various shifts the union
representing bus drivers says that is
not enough and they want a Transit
Police Department now the supervisor is
recovering from his injuries the suspect
now charged with attempted murder I'm
David charms 8 news now Brian